(television static)
(Netflix logo sound effect)
(ambient music)
- [Vincent] My friends,
when I told them about the records I had,
they were saying, "So you had Bananarama
"and you had Erasure and
you had George Michael."
They said to me, "Did
nobody know you were gay?"
My name's Vincent Creelan,
I live in Newtownards,
which is a small town in Northern Ireland.
I got married when I was in
university, when I was 19.
I thought getting married
would maybe straighten me out.
I knew, six months in, it wasn't.
I was still having a wank,
thinking about men, to be honest with you,
so I knew that strategy had failed.
In Northern Ireland, being gay,
there were just no positive messages.
I suppose the big realization was,
I was about 15, I think, in my bedroom.
I can't really remember the radio station,
but this guy was being interviewed
talking about being in a
relationship with another guy.
"I wanna tell you this," he says,
"All across UK, there are
young guys listening to this.
"They're hearing something
that means something to them,
"and they're really worried
that father or somebody
will walk into the bedroom and hear them."
That was me.
And that's when I realized that
this was kind of telling me
that I was gay and that the fears I had
and the concerns I had
and the isolation I had
was very real and I wasn't alone.
The first book I bought,
which would've been,
I suppose gay literature,
would've been A Boy's Own
Story by Edmund White.
That was the first time I read something
that I could put myself in that position,
have those same feelings
and the same crushes
he talked about on boys.
I remember reading it,
not reading it in secret
but not really saying
what the book was about.
There wasn't really much
for me to connect with
for a long, long time.
I just had to pick out
characters and people
that I either thought might
be gay or that I fancied.
I came off night shift,
a film called My Beautiful
Laundrette was on.
I thought, "Well, my wife's at work."
I realized this was a gay film
and I just had to watch it.
It felt very real for the way things were
in the world at that stage
and it was passionate
and there was kissing
and there was moments
where they just lost control
almost and took risks.
I was doing none of that, obviously,
but I looked at it and thought
that's what it could be,
and that's what I wanted.
I remember there was a
character in Eastenders.
I'm just thinking about
the kiss and it was huge.
I think they locked lips just about,
and then there's a whole fury
they report in the news, oh,
the BBC got so many complaints
and it was nothing. And yet,
you see some work where
heterosexual love and intimacy
The year I came out, it was 1997, 1998.
There still wasn't a lot to
access, to be honest with you,
and that was before Queer As Folk.
You didn't really have the internet.
Most of the stuff that was on television
was still those camp comedic
characters or performers.
But that changed, I
guess, within five years.
Queer As Folk seemed to open a door
and I think for everybody
the first episode,
it kind of set the tone for it.
The young guy goes out on the scene,
everyone was gay. Gay friends and
they were just out for a night together
and this young guy was looking for sex.
Next thing you know, he's copping off
and then he's getting naked
and then he's getting rimmed.
It was exciting, it was like
this is where it could be.
The very first time seeing as
close as you can to sex on TV,
and it was this big show and
everybody was kind of talking about it.
I tend to watch quite a bit of Netflix,
because that's where I go
for my series like Star Trek
or What If or some of the other
series that we've watched.
And you find quite often by accident
that there is a gay character
or there's a gay couple
or there's a gay theme in it.
One of the programs I recently watched
was the Tales of the City.
You always wonder when
something's re-filmed or remade,
is it really gonna stand the test?
Seeing how gay life progressed,
and then seeing some of the
characters being matured
and some of them are in relationships.
That was really good, I really enjoyed it.
I loved to watch Grace and Frankie.
Some of the truths with
their conversations,
and some of the banter,
everyone was kindof
settling into the friendships
and into the relationships.
It was lovely seeing
an older man coming out
within a very short time he found
all these gay people, he found
these gay groups to be involved in,
and he had this kindof gay life.
It's good sometimes having a comedy
in which the characters
are just being themselves
rather than where the gay character
has to be something bizarre and ridiculous
and shocking all the time.
It's good to see you reflected in a drama,
whether its a policing
drama, a science fiction one
even documentaries.
I liked seeing the life
that I perceive to be mine
which I still think
being gay or being queer
is a very different life.
I think you just get used to it and forget
how quickly it has changed
in maybe five years.
Because certainly when I
came out ten years ago,
it just, you were seeing caricatures,
comedian representations of
what straight people thought
you should see what was acceptable.
And now it seems that
there is an acceptance,
not a toleration, there is an acceptance.
A kind of celebration of what my life
and loads of other peoples lives
in what is probably one
of the largest minorities
in our societies and I have been seeing it
in social media and TV and films.